voilà 13 ans que François reppsamen
s'est installé dans cette mairie élue
dès le premier tour en 2008 avec 56% des
voix il est le grand favori à sa
succession pour certains de ses
conseillers le suspense serait même de
savoir s'il y aura un deuxième tour ou
pas mais Françoise a toujours combattu
cette idée de campagne gagner d'avance
en multipliant les réunions publiques
pour vanter son bilan fort du tramway ou
du musée des Beaux-Arts je fais une
campagne de challenger de force de
conviction de réunions dans tous les
quartiers 27 réunions donc moi je pense
que rien n'est jamais joué bien sûr j'ai
été réélu au premier tour en
2008 je sens que les gens constatent que
le bilan est bon que la villa a changé
mais pour autant il faut encore porter
les propositions à les convaincre depuis
un Ancon principal challenger Alain
houpère et sur le terrain même si le
candidat de l'UMP a dû d'abord faire
l'union dans son camp il a très vite
attaqué le bilan du maire à coup de
communiquer cinglant avec les transports
l'urbanisme et surtout la dette comme
angle d'attaque
ça représente plus d'un milliard d'euros
donc c'est cette dette qui est cachée
sur le tapis des élections qui va gêner
d'action du futur maire et le futur
maire sera
responsabilité importante d'être un
maire à plein temps d'être un maire
engagé à 200% pour faire rayonner cette
ville
parce que François hepsomen a endormi
les Dijonnais pendant 13 ans la dette
une critique qui revient aussi chez
Edouard Cavin le candidat frontiste de
24 ans incarne la jeune génération
voulue par le FN le parti de Marine Le
Pen qui avait réalisé un peu plus de
tresses pour cent au présidentielle mais
qui compte profiter d'un vote sanction
il y a un grand projet pour Dijon c'est
de baisser la fiscalité de 25% en 6 ans
ce qui représente une économie d'à peu
près 4 millions d'euros par an je crois
que c'est très important aujourd'hui
d'essayer tant que faire ce peu de
soulager le portefeuille des déjeuners
qu'il faut bien le dire est un petit peu
victime de la double peine la peine
j'allais dire du gouvernement socialiste
et la peine locale avec la politique
socialiste qui est menée par François
Epson à la gauche de la gauche cette
fois il y aura deux listes menées par
des femmes claire rocher pour Lutte
ouvrière et Isabelle de Almeida pour le
franc de gauche d'un côté la candidate
des travailleurs de l'autre l'ancienne
conseillère municipale qui veut pousser
le curseur sur le social
je pense qu'il faut porter un projet
bien ancré à gauche sur sur Dijon ce qui
manque ce qui manque actuellement donc
voilà les raisons de la constitution de
notre liste de notre démarche pour
porter des propositions contre
l'austérité pour la solidarité donc pour
plus de services publics et puis pour
plus de citoyenneté pour à permettre aux
gens de s'impliquer encore plus dans les
affaires de la cité ces élections sont
l'occasion de faire entendre le camp des
travailleurs notre camp et de dire notre
colère et notre écureuirement par
rapport à la politique qui est menée au
gouvernement depuis deux ans et qui vise
à faire payer la crise aux travailleurs
et à aider le patronat enfin il reste le
trublion l'inclassable comme beaucoup
l'ont appelé David l'anneau du grès et
sa liste apolitique venue de la société
civile lui qui a longtemps fait le buzz
avec ses idées farfelues c'est
finalement à sa vie
il y a plus de sérieux mais on reste
avec un ton quand même qui est
complètement différent en fait de celui
des autres candidats d'ailleurs c'est ce
qui fait qu'on réintéresse des gens à la
à la politique à la vie Locale de la
ville notre but c'est de réintéresser
les gens à la vie de leur cité de
ramener des gens aux urnes et si on
arrive en fait à fédérer toutes ces
personnes qui se déplaceront pas
dimanche pour aller voter et ben ce sera
déjà une belle victoire pour nous le
seul sondage sur Dijon donnait François
Epson vainqueur à 50% dès le premier
tour mais un sondage réalisé en janvier
avant le début de la campagne